[Música]
y en directo a América llegó el momento
de hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy bien Andrés y vos Bien
también Jorge vamos a empezar en Estados
Unidos con el principio de acuerdo entre
la casa blanca y los republicanos sobre
el techo de la deuda cuéntenos bueno es
importante decir que el texto en su
totalidad no ha sido publicado pero
trascendieron algunos detalles a través
de una hoja informativa distribuida Por
los republicanos el acuerdo Deja en
suspenso el techo de deuda de 31,38
billones de dólares esto permitiría al
Gobierno Federal lograr financiación y
también seguir cumpliendo sus
obligaciones de pago hasta al menos
enero del 2025 se prevé que el gasto
público no destinado a defensa se
mantenga estable durante dos años y
también aumente un 1% en el 2025 no hay
cambios en el seguro médico y la
atención médica a los veteranos el pacto
pone límite a lo que se conoce como
gasto discrecional el dinero que el
congreso asigna cada año para financiar
agencias y programas muchos programas
federales van a sufrir sin duda recortes
presupuestarios porque no habrá un
aumento debido a la inflación los
republicanos lograron introducir los
requisitos laborales para reducir
ciertos subsidios contra la pobreza
especialmente las ayudas para alimentos
por ejemplo en lugar de exigirse hasta
los 49 años se extenderá a los 54 años
para personas sin hijos también se van a
agilizar las leyes para aprobar nuevos
proyectos energéticos ahora con el 5 de
junio como fecha límite para evitar el
impago en Estados Unidos demócratas y
republicanos comienzan a cabildear para
aprobar el proyecto lo antes posible
Jorge vamos a cambiar de tema vamos a ir
a América Latina con el restablecimiento
de las relaciones entre Venezuela y
Brasil se firmaron nuevos acuerdos bueno
los países abordaron o acordaron temas
como el intercambio comercial también en
ámbito energético y la conservación del
medio ambiente el presidente brasileño
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva recordó que
tras la interrupción de las entre ambos
países el flujo pasó de 6 mil millones
de dólares al año a dos mil millones el
comercio bilateral con Venezuela alcanzó
cerca de 1700 millones en 2022 con
exportaciones brasileñas de 1.300
millones e importaciones de cerca de 400
millones de dólares el viaje Se produce
como una antesala de la Cumbre de jefes
de estado sudamericanos que convocó Lula
da Silva con el objetivo de impulsar la
integración regional a la Cumbre
asistirán representantes de Argentina
Bolivia Chile Colombia Ecuador Guyana
Paraguay Perú surinam Uruguay y
Venezuela todos confirmaron su
asistencia menos la peruana Dina
boluarte Jorge y vamos a seguir allí en
la región el parlamento chileno aprobó
una ley con histórico aumento del
salario mínimo el proyecto que reajuste
el salario mínimo hasta alcanzar de una
forma gradual y hasta julio del próximo
año los quinientos mil pesos chilenos
unos 623 dólares al cambio de hoy pero
Patricia Luna tiene todos los detalles
ahí en Chile
el congreso chileno despachó a ley un
nuevo incremento del salario mínimo que
pasará de los 512 dólares actuales a 625
en el plazo de un año a Julio de 2024 se
incrementará de forma paulatina
primeramente Se pasará de 512 a 550
después se pasará a 575 en septiembre de
este año y de ahí a 625 en julio de 2024
esto supone uno de los grandes triunfos
porque fue una de las promesas de
campaña del presidente Gabriel boric que
se comprometió a que el sueldo mínimo
alcanzará los 500.000 pesos chilenos que
equivalen a esos 225 dólares ya se había
incrementado el año pasado en unos 60
dólares aproximadamente pero se decidió
adelantar este proceso debido a el costo
que ha tenido para los chilenos en la
vida la inflación que se sitúa en 9,9%
anualizada en este momento eso supuso un
trabajo arduo para llegar a acuerdos con
todos los sectores políticos y también
para lograr subsidios para las pequeñas
y medianas empresas que también se verán
favorecidas por recortes de impuestos
entre 170.000 y 180.000 empresas
pequeñas y medianas en Chile podrán de
esta forma incrementar el salario a sus
trabajadores en total se espera que la
medida favorezca a un millón de personas
que en Chile reciben el salario mínimo
porque vamos a cambiar de tema
nuevamente hay reacciones en Turquía con
el triunfo del presidente Turco relleno
allí Perdón que extiende su mandato
Hasta 2028 qué retos hay en materia
económica bueno el principal la
inflación que disparó el costo de vida y
también reconstruir ese país tras el
devastador terremoto en El que murieron
más de 50.000 personas erdogan dijo
durante su discurso de Victoria que
habría un descenso de la tasa de
inflación que actualmente se ubica en el
43% anual pero las medidas de erdogan
han sido controversiales frente a la
inflación por ejemplo aumentar el gasto
público lo que junto con la bajada de
los tipos de interés empeoró la
inflación según los economistas el
presidente también incluyó subvenciones
a la electricidad y el gas la moneda
turca se ubica en mínimos históricos
desde las elecciones del 2018 esa moneda
local ha perdido el 80% de su valor
frente al Dólar y las reservas en
Divisas del Banco Central también están
en negativo Aunque el Banco Central de
ese país ha pronosticado que la
inflación caería al 22% para finales de
este año los economistas de bloomberg
sitúan la cifra cerca del 43% anual y
hablando de cifras Cuál es nuestra cifra
del día con una cifra no tan positiva el
consumo de cigarrillos ha causado la
muerte de
351.000 personas
351.000 personas en 8 países de América
Latina además de costos por casi 50.000
millones de dólares anuales asociados a
la atención de las enfermedades
provocadas por el tabaquismo esto según
un estudio del instituto de efectividad
clínica y sanitaria el estudio incluyó a
países como Argentina Brasil México
Colombia Costa Rica Perú Ecuador y chile
que representan el 80% de la población
de América Latina y el Caribe Jorge
muchas gracias por la información
económica nos vemos en la próxima